for more on all of it let's go now to
Robert Costa also on Capitol Hill also
tracking what's next for McCarthy and
the house speakership drama and drama is
the word for it Bob they say we haven't
seen it in a century we haven't really
seen it ever television did not exist
the last time this happened Kevin
McCarthy's making concessions what are
they and what else could he offer to get
this get this through
he has been offering concessions Tony
what happened last night were a series
of late night meetings inside the
capitol on the second floor McCarthy
gathered his critics and he said to them
look what do you really want and they
said we want Plum committee seats he
said you got it and they're just trying
to sketch out the details of an
agreement it looks like potentially five
to ten conservative hardliners could
come along today will that be enough to
get McCarthy over the edge it's not
entirely clear discussions are still
very fluid but the conservatives tell me
this morning that they feel pretty good
that McCarthy is moving in their
Direction
well here's a thought Kevin McCarthy
probably doesn't want to think about
this morning are there alternatives to
him if he steps aside and could
Democrats play a role in moving him to
the side
democrats for now and probably for this
entire process are going to hold the
line sources close to Hakeem Jeffries
the new Democratic leaders say they're
not going to offer a hand here because
it's not their obligation to solve the
Republicans problem the Democrats say
they are united around Hakeem Jeffries
and they believe that Kevin McCarthy at
the end of the day needs to fix his own
house
meantime
House of Representatives essentially a
useless arm of government we'll keep
watching it Bob thank you very much
thank you